titanfall 2 is just around the corner we
got a little taste with the open beta
that was only on ps4 and Xbox one Scott
you got to play on PC and you got to see
the three new Titans well for I suppose
yeah well yeah so finally got to play
all six like this six total Titans gonna
appear in multiplayer gotta chance play
all of them on PC and 1440 beautiful and
it's so nice to get to see all of this
content that we knew was gonna be there
but we hadn't previously had a chance to
actually play and explore so first off
there's ronin which was revealed at e3
but you know no one's actually played
him yeah and he actually might be my
favorite of the bunch to be completely
honest like what's really cool about the
Titans is each one very clearly fills a
specific role I mean not only do they
each have different abilities they all
have different amounts of health
different movement speeds they all treat
melee differently
so in Ronan's case it is the like if
you're an aggressive player if you like
getting in people's faces
this is absolutely your character for
sure so he's the sword core so like his
Ultra is basically like he pulls out
this katana and you can just run around
with hyper speed cut it not totally
dissimilar to hunters and destiny you
can just kind of like go nuts and run
around in to slice everybody up it's
awesome but even just Ronan's basic
melee is a sword attack so it kind of
looks cooler and has a little bit more
range than some of the other melee
attacks from the other Titans
okay in addition to his sword ultra he
also has a sort of phase of shift
ability right where he just like blinks
out of existence for a minute and then
pops up somewhere else and when you're
actually playing as him that that kind
of looks like your world goes black and
white all the enemies disappear but you
can still kind of see the environment so
you don't necessarily know where your
enemies are but you can kind of maneuver
through the environment just for a few
seconds and then pop back into like the
same reality as everybody else so you
can kind of use that as an escape
mechanic like if you're in too deep if
you're up to close and realize you're
about to explode you can kind of just
phase shift and leave our plane of
existence and therefore not be damaged
at all and run away but you can also use
it to kind of stealth and sneak up on
people because it's actually almost more
effective than than cloaking because no
one can see you you like are just
completely not there chase the trade-off
is you also can't necessarily see them
but if someone's like kind of planted or
camped just you know sneak up right
behind him and shove a sword through
them it's awesome
and the shotgun was really useful as
well it's like it's like three shots
then you reload you can actually do a
lot of damage with it cool so he is your
close quarters guy yeah okay and then
sort of the opposite actually I think is
the Titan that you mentioned her most
your most excited about just Northstar
yeah his default weapon is essentially a
sniper rifle which is really interesting
for a Titan because you think of the
Titans as being like you know you they
can sustain so much damage you kind of
want to be in the middle of battle but
for North Star most of his abilities are
designed to like play the space and
gameplay the range game and keep
yourself distanced from your opponent's
CS he's got basic sniper rifle his Ultra
is like he basically hovers in the air
and rains down like a barrage of
missiles which you can kind of aim a
little bit you don't have a ton of
control like once you unleash it it's
kind of just going so you have to
position yourself well before you
trigger it almost reminds me of like
Farah from overwatch totally yeah
totally fair comparison it's very
similar but like you know giant robot
instead and Nora also has sort of VTOL
of vertical takeoff and landing ability
which essentially allows North Star to
to jump so you can actually maneuver
over obstacles that no other Titan can
most the Titans are locked to the ground
and you have to just maneuver through
environments in a particular way finding
paths that are open to you not always
the case with North Star there are
certain walls that you can actually
clear and you can sort of traverse
across parts of levels in a much more
direct manner than you can with other
Titans so that's wild because I do know
in maps that were in the open beta such
as boomtown there are strict areas that
Titan cannot get to North Star would be
the only one that can get over these
walls yeah exactly
that's wild so like what about like
getting on top of rooftops like what's
the height on North Stone not super high
see that's the thing you can't that's
not like oh you can fly like no no like
yeah kind of like slowly clumsily lifts
off the ground and it's only for a short
period of time but hey that's more than
most the other Titans in any of the
other Titans come on so you do have more
mobility it's not like uh you know carte
blanche it is like I can fly to the top
of buildings like it doesn't work like
that but you are able to do more
then you can in any of the other Titans
and he also has like a shoulder-mounted
rocket that's like the recharges over
time it's not as powerful but it's you
know serves kind of that same purpose if
you want like a slightly heavier punch
or someone gets in too close you can
kind of target and take out multiple
enemies at a closer range cool so yeah
he's got kind of a little bit of
mid-range to complement his longer
distance moving on there's tone tone
tone is all about kind of like lock-on
abilities which is really interesting
yes she has some homing missiles that
are really fun to watch if you actually
lock on somebody like the reticle glows
red and you see it kind of like blink
and you know you're locked on you can
fire missiles like around corners and
watch them go up in arc and okay like
newer around a corner to get your target
which is really satisfying to like see
the Rockets curve and then in explosion
up over a building or something and know
that you hit your target it's really
cool well that's really neat because you
know having played that open beta
someone like ion who has that laser beam
a lot of times you know you care you're
kind of giving a fair warning that
you're gonna bout to unleash this weapon
on someone and that can give them time
to hop around behind like a wall all the
way so this is kind of the counter to
that right like being able to just
circumvent one if someone's running away
like if you're playing ronan for
instance you have a higher movement
speed and you're like dodging and like
boosting away and getting out of the way
tone is a great countermeasure for that
because you can get you even if you've
maneuver behind cover right that's
another really interesting just kind of
overall observation it's really cool to
see all six Titans available for play
and to see how they interact with each
other and the fact that you can switch
on the fly really allows you to adapt to
what the other team is doing because I
would say that certain matchups you you
have a bit more of an advantage and
others for example like if you are
Aronian versus a North Star on a bigger
open map like North Star totally has the
advantages even just sniper owning
before he's ever able to get up close
but on a tighter denser map like one of
the one of the new maps I got to see
which was like a very dense urban desert
kind of city there aren't as many direct
lines of sight so the North Star has a
little bit less of an advantage and
Rhoni can get in and really do a lot of
damage because it's much more close
quarters so it's interesting to see
those matchups and to see how all the
different Titans calm
in each other and yeah so circle back to
tone he doesn't have quite a sniper
rifle but he's got like a sort of
tactical marksman rifle sort of thing so
you can there's a little bit of zoom and
like a more focused reticle each shot
does a lot of damage so it that he's a
really good all-around choice of like
he's really good mix of mobility and
health and damage so probably a safe
choice for anybody starting out tremor
was his other abilities are so again
he's all about locking I believe he also
has two sonar abilities similar to one
of the pilot tactical loadouts where
like yeah there you there's a certain
tactical for pilots you can throw a
little throwing star and it emits a
sonar pulse that reveals nearby enemies
tone has a very similar ability then the
last one you're Legion yes he's kind of
like the Gatling gun heavy ammo yeah
he's got full on damaged tank guy he's
probably the most devastating in terms
of just you know attack abilities yeah
he's got this this minigun what's really
interesting about him is one of his
abilities is actually just to shift
between close and long-range firing
modes so you can switch like a
long-range focused cone of fire on the
minigun so you can be firing like a
straight line and just like hammering
every single bullet into it like a mid
to distant target but you can also
switch to that then to a more of a burst
fire mode and then the it creates sort
of like a wall of bullet that somebody
is in like walking into
he almost reminds me a little bit of
scorch in that for a mode like bounty
hunt which is solely based on just
raking up grunt kills yeah this torch
was great for basically just doing a lot
of AOE on like those drop areas and this
seems like the same case just like yo
fires the ground down like get all those
grunts yeah for sure oh god he also has
like a shield that appears over the
minigun so it's not quite like scorches
full-on flame shield but it offers a
little bit of protection against whoever
you're firing at so in a Titan on Titan
battle you throw up this life sort of
mini shield that that appears in front
of your minigun and it absorbs at least
some of the direct fire that's coming at
you excellent
yeah so it's it's a nice like defensive
consideration again one of things I
appreciate about the Titans as a whole
there are more considerations of just
attacks like each Titan sort of has a
traversal skill of some kind in a more
defensive minded skill of some kind it's
not just about weapons which was really
cool that there are sort of different
reasons to play different Titans you
know beyond just whatever the primary
attack is
well thank you Scott for a nice rundown
on the new Titans and thank you guys for
watching we have a second partner on the
multiplayer as a whole so new modes new
customisation options new abilities so
you can check that out on GameSpot
thanks for watching
[Music]